ازمه رفع سقف الدين في الولايات المتحده
تثير المخاوف في الشارع الامريكي فلا احد
يعرف على وجه اليقين ما الذي سيحدث اذا لم
يتصرف الكونجرس هذه المره وكيف ستتفاعل
الامور الماليه وهذا يقلق اصحاب المشاريع
خاصه الصغيره كروميو الذي ورث شركه طباعه
عن والده المتقاعد وما زال اصلا يعاني من
تداعيات جائحه كورونا
هذا يشعرني بالتوتر لانني لا اعرف كيف
ستكون الظروف الماليه المرتبطه بعدم
اليقين هذا لذا حتى يحل الكونجرس والرئيس
الازمه ستكون الكثير من استثمارات في
صندوق التقاعد الخاص بي تحت الضغط
وفي ظل الجدل بين البيت الابيض الذي يطالب
برفع سقف الدين من دون شروط والجمهوريين
الذين يشترطون خفضا في الانفاق الحكومي
لتحقيق ذلك عبر اخرون عن استيائهما مما
وصفوه بتلاعب المسؤولين بمستقبل البلد من
اج ل تحقيق اهداف اجنداتهم السياسيه
انا لا افهم كيف يمكن للحزب الجمهوري ان
يفعل ذلك وعندما كانوا مسؤولين لم تكن هذه
مشكله لا افهم كيف اننا جميعا لدينا
فواتير ولم يعد بامكاننا الاتصال بالاشخاص
الذين لهم بالمال ونقول لهم ما لم تفعل
هذا من اجلنا فلن ندفع لك انه حد الجنون
الفشل في رفع سقف الدين وفق مراقبين لا
يهدد فقط الانفاق الخاضعه للاعتمادات
السنويه من قبل الكونجرس ولكن كل الانفاق
الفيدرالي ويشمل ذلك الضمان الاجتماعي
والرعايه الطبيه والمزايا الحكوميه الاخرى
كما يمكن ان تتاخر رواتب الموظفين
الفيدراليين حسين العربيه واشنطن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات